I don't think we all have divided I
think the support for that speech was
overwhelming she set out clear
conservative policies she is prayer
grade and we have helped people with
their energy bills we have shown that we
are a tax cutting government that
believes people spend their own money
better than the state spends it for them
this was a really proper conservative
speech which will be very unified you
said the parties is best when it works
together I mean it's not working
together you cannot say this week has
gone to plan has it well we're clearly
working on a plan for growth for the
economy what does that mean that means
that people's money goes further that
it's easier for them to buy the goods
that they need that their pay will go up
that and it will because of the cutting
National Insurance and The Cutting
income tax people have more money in
their pockets they will have a better
standard of living that's what it's all
about as Disraeli used to put it some
time ago it's about improving the
condition of the people that's what the
conservative governments have always
hoped to do reports this morning that
you want to see benefits rise in line
with inflation that is at odds with the
hints coming from number 10 and
um
with the Prime Minister either this one
or the previous one
um but as far as I'm aware the decision
hasn't been made and there's a legal
process as stature instrument has to be
laid I think the sexual safe work and
pensions has certain Authority in this
area
but governments discuss decisions before
they're made and then they get made and
then they get supported that's the
normal process of government okay what's
the PM going to do now to heal divisions
with the back benches it's pretty clear
that people are angry that that is
something she needs to do well I'm not
sure isn't that clear that people are
angry there are always some moaning
minis look I used to do this at party
conferences and go around and say that
we I think things should be done
differently when I was on the back
benches that's what backbenchers do so
you don't think she needs to do anything
to heal divisions on the back benches
what we need is exactly what's set out
good conservative policies and that's
what she's offering and look at the
response she got absolutely brilliant
and class did she still alive from kirst
armor some reports that she said growth
growth gross those are three priorities
that's something that kirstalmer said a
couple years ago in a speech oh lord
well I haven't studied secure speeches
carefully enough this has been most
remiss of me to work out every phrase
that he has ever used